เฮ [música]
[música]
>> [música]
>> เ
[música]
>> เ เฮ
เฮ
[música]
>> [música]
>> Olá, [música]
[música]
pessoal. Tudo bem com vocês? E sejam
muito bem-vindos e muito bem-vindas a
esse encontro de hoje, um encontro sobre
parte especial, contratos dentro aí do
nosso curso de direito civil, reta
final, para o exame de ordem, que vai
acontecer domingo, né? estaremos juntos
aí domingo e eu não posso deixar de te
lembrar que no sábado teremos a nossa
revisão de véspera aí, é sobre e no
domingo teremos o nosso pós-prova
ao vivo no canal aqui do GR OAB. E hoje,
aliás, eu já quero mandar um beijo muito
especial para todo mundo que tá aí ao
vivo acompanhando a gente, tá? Hoje
nossa disciplina aqui, ó, linda, linda,
linda, da parte de contratos.
Aliás, já quero até te lembrar que a
gente já estudou
parte de eh sucessões, família, coisas,
responsabilidade civil. Hoje a gente vai
para contratos, amanhã à noite estaremos
juntos com obrigações e, salvo engano,
na sexta-feira estaremos juntos com
parte geral e a nossa última parte do
direito civil, né? Bom, um beijo para
todo mundo que tá aí ao vivo
acompanhando a gente. Diogo, Marcela,
Steve,
eh, Sérgio, Letícia, Ana, Nani, Gcimara,
Fernanda, Maria, Vanessa, galera que tá
aí se manifestando, Gabriel lá de João
Pessoa, um beijo para vocês. Estamos
juntos nesse encontro, né? Um encontro
muito especial já na reta final real
oficial. Mas gente, deixa eu falar uma
coisa, Elda, um beijo.
Que que a gente teria para conversar
sobre a parte de contratos, né? O que
que seria importante, Ana, um beijo. O
que que seria importante trabalharmos
aqui hoje nessa parte relacionada a
direito dos contratos? Vamos aqui ao
nosso material. Vamos começar o nosso
esquema do coração, né?
Vamos lá, iniciando as nossas anotações.
Quando a gente fala basicamente
de contratos,
nós encontramos
a grande fonte de obrigações.
Então, dentro dos contratos, a gente tem
fonte obrigacional.
E onde tem obrigação,
sempre tem uma relação entre credor
e devedor.
Então, basicamente, pensou em contrato,
você lembra
de obrigações
e aí você lembra da relação
de credor
e devedor,
tá?
Agora, um ponto interessante
é você observar que os contratos, que os
contratos
eles são
celebrados
mediante a redação das cláusulas
contratuais.
E nós temos dois tipos
possíveis de estipulação de cláusulas
contratuais.
Nós temos os contratos chamados de
paritários
e nós temos o o chamado contrato de
adesão
no direito civil. A regra é que os
contratos sejam paritários.
Então, presume-se paritários,
presumem-se paritários os contratos.
No direito civil.
Quando você pega um contrato,
presumidamente você pensa naquele
contrato como sendo um contrato
paritário.
Excepcionalmente nós vamos falar que
aquele contrato é de adesão. Ah,
Roberta, mas
na vida real mesmo o que eu mais
encontro é contrato de adesão. Sim,
acaba sendo. O que que é o contrato de
adesão que constitui a exceção?
O contrato de adesão é aquele contrato
que já tem as cláusulas contratuais
previamente estipuladas.
O contratado já vem com o contrato
pronto. Exemplo, contrato de plano de
saúde, contrato de
eh,
como é que fala aqui?
Esqueci o nome. Seguro, né? contratos de
prestação de serviço, já vem com as
cláusulas prontas.
Esses contratos são chamados de
contratos de adesdão. Se cair na sua
prova uma questão contextualizada
falando: "Ah, e biibi bobó e celebrou um
contrato de adesão e aí agora existe a
necessidade de interpretar cláusulas
contratuais. Como que o juiz deve fazer?
ou se caiu uma questão na sua prova
falando sobre contrato de adesão e
falando que dentro do contrato de adesão
havia uma cláusula prevendo uma renúncia
antecipada
de algum direito da parte contratante,
ou seja, o aderente estaria renunciando
antecipadamente a algum direito. Você
acha que faz sentido você colocar num
contrato de adesão no qual o aderente
para ter o seu serviço, seu produto,
ele vai ter que se submeter a aquelas
cláusulas e [limpando a garganta] eh ele
vai ter que se submeter a aquelas
cláusulas e no final a gente vai
observar que tem uma renúncia antecipada
ali. ele estaria renunciando
antecipadamente um eventual direito por
uma situação que que, né, de acordo com
uma cláusula que ele não participou da
redação, ele só tinha como aderir à
aquela cláusula, senão ele não teria
acesso à prestação do serviço. Como que
fica essa história? Vamos lá. Nos
contratos de adesão,
duas situações podem cair na sua prova,
tá? como ele é exatamente a exceção.
Duas informações são importantes.
A primeira informação é que se houver
necessidade
de interpretação
do contrato,
essa interpretação ela deve ser mais
favorável,
mais favorável.
Eu vou interpretar de maneira mais
favorável
ao aderente,
que é quem não redigiu a cláusula
contratual.
E são completamente nulas.
São completamente nulas.
Eu e minha síndrome aqui do caderno, né,
são completamente nulas.
eventuais
renúncias
antecipadas
a direitos antecipadas
a determinados direitos, tá? Então,
esses dois pontos são relevantes paraa
sua prova: interpretação e nulidade.
Em tempo, imagina você essa questão de
prova aqui, ó,
que já caiu. Imagina você essa questão
aqui, ó.
Imagina você que o João,
filho
da Maria,
filho da Maria, e a Maria tem muito,
muito dinheiro.
Ele é inclusive herdeiro
único,
herdeiro único da Maria.
Maria tá viva, tá de boa. Ele resolve
ceder
a futura
herança.
Que se a Maria morresse hoje seria 10
milhões. Imagina, é muito dinheiro.
para o amigo José,
para o amigo
José,
pelo valor
pelo valor de 1 milhão. Tipo, o cara tá
precisando de dinheiro. Ele foi lá e fez
um contrato
cedendo a futura herança
para o amigo José pelo valor de 1 milhão
deais.
Ou seja, ele fez
uma sessão
onerosa da futura herança que ele tem
direito.
A minha pergunta é:
ele pode fazer isso?
Esse tipo de questão já caiu em prova,
Gente, um detalhe importante,
um detalhe importante, nós temos um
artigo que é esse artigo aqui, o 426.
O 426
é o artigo do coração dessa questão
aqui, porque ele diz o seguinte:
Não pode ser objeto,
não pode ser objeto de contrato herança
de pessoa viva.
E o que que eu quero que você lembre?
Quando a lei proíbe
determinado ato sem combinar sanção,
qual seria outra sanção? dizer que o ato
é anulável. Se a lei proíbe a prática de
um ato, se a lei proíbe a prática de um
ato, sem cominar sanção,
sem combinar sanção,
este ato é nulo se for praticado.
Quem diz isso? O artigo
166,
inciso 7.
O 166 trabalha quais são os atos nulos,
né? O 166 fala: "São nulos os atos?"
Bibi, bobó. Quais são os atos nulos? Aí
o inciso sete diz: "Aqueles
proibidos pela lei." Eu vou abrir para
você aqui o nosso Código Civil para te
mostrar, porque eu tenho essa
essa síndrome, né, gente? Vamos lá.
Dá uma olhada aqui. Estamos aqui no
Código Civil. Eu vou direto lá no 166.
Olha
lá, é nulo o negócio jurídico quando
todas essas possibilidades e o sete, a
lei taxativamente declarar nulo ou a lei
proibir a prática sem combinar sanção.
Se a lei proibir a prática sem combinar
sanção, nós temos um ato que é nulo e é
exatamente o exemplo do artigo 426.
Se não pode ser objeto de contrato de
contrato herança de pessoa viva, a lei
tá proibindo a prática. Se a lei proíbe
a prática e alguém pratica, este ato é
nulo. Então, no nosso caso aqui, quando
a Maria morrer, vamos botar aqui, ó,
quando
Maria
falecer,
esse contrato, como ele não é válido, a
herança vai para
o João
e o José vai ficar a ver navios porque
ele ele não vai receber dessa herança, a
não ser que o João receba e entregue
para ele de boa vontade, mas este
contrato é um contrato nulo, OK? Então
esse contrato de sessão que ele fez aqui
é completamente o quê, pessoal?
Completamente
nulo, OK? Completamente nulo, sem medo
de ser feliz.
Um outro ponto que também pode ser
comprado, cobrado em prova, é que os
contratos, via de regra, produzem
efeitos entre as partes, né? Nós temos
aqui que os contratos eles possuem uma
uma relatividade
entre as partes. Eles produzem efeitos
entre as partes. Então, olha o que nós
vamos anotar.
Nós temos duas situações específicas.
a regra
que diz:
"Todo contrato celebrado
produz
efeitos
entre as partes. Que partes? Contratante
e contratado. Isso é
o chamado
princípio da relatividade dos contratos.
Princípio da relatividade dos contratos.
Vou botar mais para cá, né? Porque ficou
parecendo um
princípio da relatividade
dos contratos. Ou seja, os contratos
produzem efeitos entre contratante e
contratado. De modo que se você não é
nem contratante, nem contratado, não tem
como esse contrato te atingir, né?
Mas
pasme,
nós temos exceção
e a exceção é exatamente
o oposto.
O que que é a exceção?
É o contrato
é o contrato
atingir
terceiros.
É o contrato atingir terceiros.
Professora, como assim? Como assim? Eu
vou até botar de outra cor aqui, ó. Como
assim um contrato pode atingir um
terceiro? Me explica,
gente. O contrato pode atingir terceiro
de três maneiras
que já duas delas já foram cobradas e
uma nunca foi cobrada. Então eu tenho
três possibilidades
A, B e C.
As duas primeiras já foram cobradas em
prova e a terceira nunca foi cobrada,
mas vai que nós temos, respectivamente
estipulação
em
favor
de terceiro.
Vou explicar para você com exemplo.
Começa
de fato
de terceiro
e o último que é o contrato
com
pessoa
a
declarar,
respectivamente
previstos nos seguintes dispositivos.
Estipulação em favor de terceiro, artigo
a 438.
Promessa de fato de terceiro, artigo 439
a A não e 440.
Contrato com pessoa declarar
artigo 467
A 471.
Tá? Vamos lá. Como que funciona isso e
quais são os exemplos que nós temos
relacionados a isso?
Estipulação em favor de terceiro. Eu
celebro um contrato com você estipulando
algo que vai favorecer um terceiro, que
é chamado de beneficiário.
O clássico exemplo é o contrato de
seguro de vida. Contrato de seguro de
vida. Eu posso estipular, aliás, os
contratos de seguro agora não são mais
previstos no Código Civil, são previstos
no marco legal da dos seguros, que é uma
lei nova que passou a ter vigência em
dezembro de 2025, tá? Já temos aula de
contratos de seguro com a legislação
atual no nosso curso.
Um, o contrato de seguro de vida. Eu
faço o seguro de vida
estipulando um benefício para alguém. Ou
seja, o que que é a essência do contrato
de seguro de vida? A essência do
contrato de seguro de vida é exatamente
você observar que se eu se eu não quando
eu morrer, que é a única certeza que a
gente tem, é a morte, né? Quando eu
morrer,
quem eu indico como beneficiário vai
receber o valor da indenização. Esse é o
seguro de vida. É um contrato celebrado,
por exemplo, entre mim, Roberta e o
banco
X, e
a pessoa aí beneficiada, indicada como
beneficiário, vai receber esse eh essa
indenização, tá? Vamos lá. Então, o
exemplo aqui que a gente tem, vou
colocar aqui exemplo,
contrato
de seguro
de vida, tá?
A promessa de fato de terceiro, promessa
de fato de terceiro também já foi
cobrada em prova. Também já foi cobrado
em prova. O que que seria essa prometa?
Promessa de fato de terceiro seria eu
prometer algo envolvendo um terceiro
qualquer.
Eu gosto de um exemplo
muito específico que você super vai
entender isso aqui, mas isso aqui também
já caiu em prova. Então, olha o exemplo
que eu gosto. Imagina que eu tenho uma
casa de uma casa não, uma empresa de
cerimonial de festa. Eu tenho uma
empresa de organização de festa e essa
empresa de organização de festa, ela
fornece todos os serviços essenciais
para uma festa bacana.
E aí você tá procurando uma empresa
nesse sentido para organizar a sua festa
de casamento. E aí eu falo: "Olha, se
você fechar sua festa de casamento
comigo,
você, eu prometo, olha lá, eu prometo
que eu vou levar Ivete Sangalo para
tocar na sua festa. Eu adoro esse
exemplo. Que que Ivete tem a ver na fila
da goiaba?
Eu, Roberta, tô prometendo um fato que
vai ser cumprida cumprido pela EVET. Eu
tenho alguma coisa a ver com isso?
Total. E ela tem alguma coisa a ver com
isso? Total de zero a ver com isso.
Então, o terceiro que foi prometido não
se vincula ao cumprimento de uma
promessa de fato que ele deveria fazer,
mas que foi feita por outra pessoa.
Resumo da opera. e Vet não se vinculou.
Caiu uma questão antiga na prova da OAB
relacionada assim: eh, o João prometeu
que o primo famoso iria dar uma
entrevista na rádio e ele não foi. Quem
responde? O primo prometido de
comparecer na rádio ou quem prometeu?
Quem prometeu? Então, no final das
contas, na promessa de fato de terceiro,
o terceiro prometido não se vincula.
Tá? O terceiro prometido não se vincula.
O terceiro prometido não tem nada a ver
com a história.
O promente,
nesse caso,
o promente
responde
pela promessa feita.
Ele responde pela promessa feita. O
prometente é quem prometeu e o terceiro
não se vincula.
O terceiro,
o terceiro
não
se obriga,
tá?
O terceiro não se obriga.
O terceiro, ele só vai se obrigar
se ele aceitar. Por exemplo, eu ligo
para Ivete e falo: "Ivete, eu prometi
aqui que você vai tocar numa festa de
casamento que eu tô organizando". Ela
fala: "Tá bom, minha irmã, aceito e eu
contratualizo com ela." Aí,
aí.
ela passa a ser responsável pela
promessa que ela fez de comparecer.
Então, o terceiro só se vincula se ele
expressamente aceitar o que foi objeto
de promessa, tá bom? [roncando]
E o contrato com pessoa a declarar é
você celebrar mesmo um contrato com uma
pessoa que ainda será declarada por
alguém.
Por exemplo, eu quero fazer uma doação,
tá? Eu quero fazer uma doação,
só que eu quero fazer uma doação para
uma creche
e eu não conheço nenhuma creche, mas
você conhece várias porque você já faz
um trabalho eh voluntário com crianças
carentes. Aí eu falo, faço uma doação de
R$ 10.000
para a creche a ser indicada.
pela Maria. Isso é um contrato com
pessoa que será será declarada pela
Maria. Tá bom? São as formas de
celebração de contratos atingindo
terceiros. Dá o print nessa tela aí.
Dá o print nessa tela aí. Tá. Outro
ponto importante que eu gosto de
trabalhar com vocês na parte de
contratos,
os contratos, essa daqui agora é boa,
tá? Os contratos
são formados,
vamos falar aqui da formação
dos contratos.
Os contratos
são formados
pela simples manifestação de vontade.
Sabia disso?
Aliás, isso
é o que dá nome
ao chamado
princípio
do
consensualismo.
Os contratos são são formados pela
manifestação
de vontade,
tá? Os contratos são formados pela
manifestação de vontade.
Eh, neste ponto, se eu digo sim, eu faço
a minha proposta e você aceita, o
contrato tá formado. Então, vamos lá.
Vamos aqui a um caso
de prova.
Ai, professora, esses casos de prova
é por meio deles que a gente memoriza a
matéria e eles viram e mexe voltam a ser
cobrados.
Vamos lá.
Imagina você que o João
oferece
o celular
para
José
por
R$ 1.000.
OK. Ele fala: "José, aceita comprar o
meu celular por R$ 1.000?
O José
prontamente
aceita,
tá? Que horas que o contrato tá formado?
Se o contrato é formado pela
manifestação de vontade,
eu tenho a oferta e a aceitação, tá?
Então, eu tenho aqui a oferta feita
pelo eh ofertante e a aceitação do
aceitante.
Eu tenho a oferta e a aceitação.
A oferta que é o mesmo que proposta
que é aceita.
na aceitação
também chamada de
poblação.
Então eu tenho proposta e aceitação, tá?
Quando é que o contrato está formado?
Simplesmente por essa situação. Eu tenho
o sim do ofertante e o sim do aceitante.
Aqui contrato formado, ou seja, o
contrato já existe.
Contrato formado, contrato existente.
Ponto. Roberta,
o José
precisa
pagar
para formar o contrato?
Não.
Por que que não?
Porque o contrato é formado pela simples
manifestação de vontade.
Roberta,
o João
precisa
entregar
a coisa
para formar o contrato
também não. Por quê? Porque o contrato é
formado pela manifestação de vontade.
Tudo bem? Olha essa outra pergunta aqui.
Se o João,
aliás, se o José, que é o comprador,
pagar
pela coisa,
ele passa a ser dono?
Que que você me diz? Essa pergunta aqui
é boa. Se você me me pergunta assim,
Roberto, aceita comprar meu celular por
R$ 1.000? Eu digo: "Sim, aceito. E eu te
pago o celular por R$ 1.000. Eu te
entrego R$ 1.000. Significa que eu já
sou dona do celular? Significa que eu
sou a dona do celular? Que que você me
diz? Claro que não, porque uma coisa é
uma coisa, outra coisa é outra coisa.
Uma coisa é a formação do contrato,
outra coisa completamente diferente,
completamente diferente é a propriedade.
A gente já estudou propriedade. Como que
eu me torno proprietária de uma coisa
móvel? Pela tradição. Quando eu pego
essa coisa para mim, como que eu me
torno proprietária de uma coisa, o
Severo já colocou ali, de uma coisa
imóvel pelo registro. Então, o simples
pagamento da coisa não transforma a
pessoa em dono. Deixa eu botar de
vermelho.
Não.
Não. Ou seja, dono
é só quando, neste caso aqui, acontecer
a tradição, que é a entrega da coisa,
tá? De modo que se o João vende a coisa
para outra pessoa e essa outra pessoa
pega a coisa,
quem vai ser o dono é essa outra pessoa,
tá? Quem vai ser o dono é essa outra
pessoa.
Tudo bem?
Show de bola.
Tá. Dá o print nessa tela aí. Vamos
embora.
Dá o print nessa tela. Aí
um outro detalhe super interessante
que pode ser efetivamente cobrado na sua
prova é o seguinte.
Imagina [limpando a garganta] que a
gente tem aqui
um imóvel,
tá? Imagina que a gente tem aqui um
imóvel.
Nós temos três três donos deste imóvel.
Nós temos três donos deste imóvel.
Porque o que que aconteceu? Imagina você
que o João
vendeu
essa casa
para três pessoas.
Maria,
Antônio
e
José.
Maria.
Então, portanto, vai ser dona de 1/3 do
imóvel.
Antônio, que será dono
de 1/3 deste imóvel
e, obviamente,
o José que será dono de 1/3
do imóvel. Tudo bem?
Nesse caso, nós temos o quê? Nós temos
uma copropriedade,
porque nós temos propriedade de várias
pessoas. Se eu tenho uma copropriedade,
olha que interessante,
copriedade,
eu tenho propriedade de vários. Se eu
tenho propriedade de vários, eu tenho um
com
do domínio.
OK? E aqui a gente tem a incidência do
artigo 504.
Esse artigo 504 eu quero que você guarde
no coração,
porque esse 504 ele traz uma informação
muito importante, que é quando nós
estivermos diante da venda de cota parte
em qual propriedade. Olha o que que a
gente vai colocar aqui no nosso
material.
que a gente não é besta.
Olha lá,
não pode. Olha o material. Preste
atenção agora.
Olha lá. Não pode
um condômino em coisa indivisível. A
casa é indivisível? Sim.
vender, vender, doar, ele pode, ele não
pode vender, porque se ele quiser doar,
ele doa para quem quiser.
A parte a estranhos, se outro consorte a
quiser tanto por tanto. Então, o que que
a gente tem aqui? Ficou estranho, né?
Vou botar aqui, ó. Não pode vender sua
parte. Achei estranho se outro com sorte
quiser
quiser tanto por tanto. Então se a
Maria, veja, o João vendeu pra Maria,
formou-se então aqui entre eles
o quê? Uma copropriedade.
Eu tenho propriedade de três pessoas.
Imagina que a Maria,
a Maria decide vender
o 1/3 dela. Se ela quiser doar, ela faz
a doação para quem ela quiser. Doação
ela faz para quem ela quiser. Mas se ela
quiser vender 1/3 dela, ela tem que
fazer o quê? Esse 1/3 dela, ela tem que
oferecer
para quem? para o Antônio
e o José, que são os outros, para que
eles possam adquirir a parte dela,
porque eles têm preferência. O 504
trabalha o direito de preência,
tá? O direito de preferência
na aquisição do bem do 1/3. Roberta, se
ela não oferecer, olha lá, o condômino,
a quem não se der conhecimento da venda,
poderá depositando
o preço, depositando o preço, a ver para
si a parte vendida a estranhos.
Ora, o que que significa isso? Ele
poderá
adjudicar
se não der a ele a propriedade,
a propriedade não, a possibilidade de
comprar o bem, ele poderá adjudicar,
ele poderá adjudicar daquela cota parte,
como ele poderá adjudicar
no prazo de 180 dias sob pena de de
decadência. Então ele pode adjudicar em
dias. Vou até botar de laranja aqui.
Poderá haver para si a parte a
estranhos. E como que eu tomo para mim
algo? Como é que eu pego algo para mim?
Eu pego algo para mim por meio do
fenômeno da adjudicação, tá? A
adjudicação é exatamente essa
sistemática de tomar para si algo, tá?
Tomar para si algo. Eu vou tomar em 180
dias. Roberta, mas e se o Antônio e o
José quiserem? Se os dois quiserem isso,
se os dois fizerem questão de adquirir a
cota a parte da Maria, aí a gente vai
ter que fazer meio que um sisteminha de
eh licitação entre eles. Olha só como é
que vai funcionar.
sendo muitos os condôminos,
preferirá quem tem no bem benfeitorias
de maior valor.
Na falta de benfeitorias, tipo, ninguém
tem benfeitorias de maior valor,
quem tem o quinhão maior, nesse caso, o
quinhão de todo mundo é igual, porque é
1/3 para todo mundo.
Se as partes forem iguais, haverão a
parte vendida, os coproprietários que a
quiserem, depositando previamente o
preço. Então, a forma de desempate, se
todo mundo quiser, será quem tem mais
benfeitorias.
Se não for o caso, quem tem maior
quinhão.
Se não for o caso, se não for o caso,
quem fizer primeiro o pagamento.
OK? Então, essas são as formas de
desempate. Beleza? Essa questão pode
cair na sua prova porque é uma questão
muito boa de prova da OAB, muito boa
mesmo. Tá bom? Bom, e como a gente tá
falando aqui de contrato de de negócio,
né, de contratos, eu quero conversar com
você sobre um ponto bastante relevante
em prova relacionada à questão de
contratos.
O pai pode vender o carro pro filho?
Pode. O pai pode doar o carro pro filho.
Pode também. O pai pode trocar o carro
dele com o carro do filho? Pode também.
São três contratos diferentes, compra e
venda, doação, troca ou permuta.
E são três consequências diferentes.
Vamos falar disso. Vamos lá, então. Dá o
print nessa tela aí e vamos seguir o
bonde. Vamos lá.
O pai
ou a mãe
pode,
vamos botar aqui o exemplo do carro, mas
pode ser uma casa, pode ser um
apartamento, pode ser o que você quiser.
Trocar, vender, doar para o filho ou
filha.
Nós temos três possibilidades:
vender,
doar,
trocar.
Vamos lá.
O pai pode
vender o carro pro filho.
Hipótese dois.
O pai pode
doar
o carro pro filho.
Hipótese três.
O pai pode
trocar
o carro dele com o carro do filho.
Tá vendo aqui?
São três situações distintas.
A primeira
que é venda, a segunda que é doação e a
terceira que é uma troca. Três situações
distintas que envolvem contratos
diferentes.
O primeiro caso da compra e venda,
artigo 496.
Artigo
496.
Obrigada, viu, Elda, fico feliz.
Artigo 496.
O pai pode doar o bem pro filho. Ele
pode doar o bem pro filho. Deixa eu ver
se eu consigo adicionar aqui
o artigo.
Vamos lá.
Tá vendo aqui?
Vou puxar até
para cá para você observar. Estamos
falando da venda, tá? Olha aqui o
código. Deixa eu aumentar a letra.
Olha aqui, ó.
é anulável a venda de ascendente a
descendente,
salvo
se outros descendentes e o cônjuge do
alienante expressamente houverem
consentido.
Então, presta atenção aqui.
Presta atenção aqui.
Se a gente tá falando,
se a gente tá falando de compra e venda,
o artigo 496, ele diz que é anulável se
não tiver consentimento. Então eu
preciso de quê para compra e venda? Eu
preciso de quê? Eu preciso de
consento.
Eu preciso de consentimento de quem?
do cônjuge daquele pai.
Do cônjuge daquele pai,
salvo se for casado no regime da
separação obrigatória,
salvo separação obrigatória de bens.
Aí não precisa. E eu preciso do
consentimento dos outros
descendentes,
daquele pai.
Se faltar esse consentimento, olha a
merda. Se faltar esse consentimento,
vai dar ruim.
A venda é anulável
no prazo de 2 anos.
Tudo bem? Muito simples, né? De boa.
O pai pode doar o bem pro filho.
Meu pai pode me dar um carro, por
exemplo. Pode. Aqui a gente vai ter a
incidência do artigo 54.
Professora, vai precisar de
consentimento. Olha o que diz o 544.
A doação de ascendente a descendente ou
de um cônjuge a outro importa
adiantamento do que lhe cabe por
herança. Então, no 544
precisa de consentimento,
precisa de consentimento. Que que você
me diz? Claro que não. Então, a gente
risca.
Não precisa de consentimento, mas a
partir do momento que o pai entrega um
bem, já configura o quê?
Adiantamento
de legítima, que é o mesmo de
adiantamento de herança.
Vou puxar essa setinha mais para baixo
aqui,
OK?
Botar aqui assim, ó.
já configura adiantamento de legítimo,
de modo que aquele filho
recebedor
daquele bem em vida, quando o pai
falecer,
ele tem o dever de quê? Dever de quê? de
colação, ou seja, de acordo com o artigo
2002 do Código Civil, aquele filho que
recebeu aquela herança em aquela herança
não, aquele bem em vida lá quando do
falecimento daquele pai, lá no momento
do inventário, ele vai ter que dizer:
"Juiz, eu já recebi um determinado valor
em vida".
Ponto.
E aí esse valor que ele recebeu vai ser
feito abatimento.
Já caiu em prova da OAB. Teria como o
pai doar o bem pro filho e dispensar o
filho dessa colação? Que que você me
diz? Sim. É possível dispensar? Sim.
Pode dispensar? Pode
desde que ele,
o pai informe que aquele bemu
da parte disponível do seu patrimônio.
Quanto que é a parte disponível? 50%.
Conforme o artigo 2005
do Código Civil.
Tudo bem?
vai ter que informar que aquele bem saiu
da parte disponível.
Beleza.
Maravig gold. Maravig gold. Isso, nera.
Curtiu?
Agora me diga uma coisa.
Me diga uma coisa.
Será que o pai,
o pai pode trocar o bem com o filho?
Tipo, eu tenho o meu carro e eu quero
trocar
com o carro do meu pai.
Troco carro. Carro eu troco. É possível?
Vamos aqui no nosso material.
Professora, me mostra o artigo.
Vamos lá.
Aqui a gente vai mostrar o artigo 533,
que diz o seguinte: troca ou permuta,
aplicam-se atos troca as disposições
referentes à compra e venda com as
seguintes modificações. Olha para cá. É
anulável a troca de valores desiguais,
desiguais entre ascendentes e
descendentes.
Tem consentimento do outro descendente e
do cônjuge do alienante. Igual que nem
na compra e venda. Na compra e venda eu
preciso do consentimento. Na troca eu
preciso do consentimento. Depende.
[roncando]
Depende de que, Roberta? Pelo amor de
Deus. Vamos lá. Presta atenção aqui.
Artigo 533.
Troca entre pai e filho.
Eu preciso do consentimento.
Vamos pegar e fazer o mesmo desenho.
Vou pegar aqui, ó.
Eu
fiz uma cagadinha.
preciso do consentimento da criatura.
Que que vocês me falam aí das criaturas,
né? No caso, eu preciso, vou copiar aqui
como imagem.
Na troca ou permuta eu vou precisar do
consentimento. Que que você me diz?
Depende,
depende. Eu vou precisar do
consentimento
a depender a depender do valor.
Se o valor entre os bens
for
igual,
aliás, se o valor entre os bens
for igual,
eu não preciso.
Mas se os valores forem desiguais para
evitar camuflar uma compra e venda,
eu preciso.
Porque se eu não der o consentimento, eu
aplico a mesma regra.
Eu
preciso aplicar a mesma regra
da anulabilidade.
Ficou ruim, né?
Tudo bem?
Eu aplico a mesma regra da compra e
venda.
Dá o print nessa tela aí.
Já que a gente falou sobre doação,
vamos ver,
vamos ver um pouquinho sobre contrato de
doação. Que que você acha?
doação tem caído muito, né? Doação tem
sido um contrato, uma modalidade
contratual que tem sido muito cobrada,
muito, muito cobrada. E
engraçado que essa
doação ela são regras ali
e muito cobradas de fato, mas tem alguns
pontos específicos dentro do contrato de
doação que são bastante cobrados. Vamos
fazer um esqueminha do coração.
Vamos lá
dá o print aqui nessa tela.
Eh,
doação,
doação
e uma pausa, né? Uma pausa,
uma pausa rápida. Vocês estão percebendo
que eu tô com a cabeça um pouco voada
hoje, né?
Tô tô com a cabeça um pouco assim aérea
hoje.
Eh, vou nem ficar falando muito, senão
daqui a pouco começo a chorar aqui ao
vivo. Mas
só para comentar uma coisa aqui com
vocês, a prova tá chegando, né? E eu sei
que vocês ficam muito, muito, muito
agoniados com a prova, ficam muito
ansiosos
e vocês colocam
a vida inteira de vocês
nessa prova. Eu sei que vocês fazem isso
e às vezes nessa dificuldade que vocês
estão caminhando ali
da prova de vocês, vocês pensam que isso
é tudo na vida.
Meu Deus, eu só vou ser feliz se eu
passar, eu só vou conseguir se eu
passar. Eu só vou conseguir ter isso, X,
Y, Z se eu passar.
Enfim, a gente acaba associando coisas
que a gente quer muito à nossa
felicidade plena. Só que não vai
acontecer de você ficar feliz plenamente
depois da sua aprovação. É óbvio que
você vai ficar feliz, mas logo logo, e
graças a Deus isso acontece, você vai
procurar outra coisa para acrescentar na
sua vida.
você vai querer abrir seu escritório ou
você vai querer conquistar o primeiro
cliente, a gente acaba substituindo
as nossas felicidades, digamos assim,
quando a gente alcança uma, a gente
busca outra. E graças a Deus é assim,
porque é o nosso sonho. E aí vocês olham
pra gente
aqui, ah, é professora Roberta, tem o
escritório dela, tem a vida dela, tem
tudo que ela quer, tem os cachorros
dela, os gatos dela, a casa dela, o
carro dela, a vida dela, tudo. E aí
vocês falam assim: "Essa pessoa é
feliz".
Aquela outra pessoa é feliz.
Ai, o dia que eu for igual à aquela
pessoa, eu vou vou estar feliz. Larga de
besteira.
Porque tudo que você vê em rede social,
tudo que você vê aqui na tela,
é uma,
é só o que a gente quer mostrar, né? O
que você vê em rede social é o que a
pessoa quer mostrar. E ninguém quer
mostrar a infelicidade,
mas todos nós temos problemas. Eu acho
que no momento agora, não vou dizer que
eu tô passando o momento mais difícil,
mas eu estou passando um dos mais
difíceis, vários problemas, né? saúde da
minha mãe, do meu pai, várias questões,
minhas questões pessoais que a gente
acaba desenvolvendo ao longo da vida
algumas crenças e a gente acaba
precisando eh mudar um pouco essas
crenças e é muito difícil se desapegar
de algumas realidades,
eh incertezas na vida pessoal,
profissional, mas eu não tenho outra
alternativa se não seguir. Eu dormi um
total de zero minutos essa noite,
preocupada com as coisas, sabe?
Angustiada, preocupada, triste pelo
acontecimento de certas coisas que não
dependiam de mim, mas enfim, aconteceram
e me atingiram.
E eu vou dizer para você, eu tô aqui. Eu
tô aqui e eu vou seguir.
Independentemente
de mim, a vida vai seguir. Então, melhor
que siga eu fazendo esforço todos os
dias para conseguir melhorar. E eu
desejo isso para você. Sabe por quê?
Pode parecer a coisa mais boba do mundo.
Sabe aquela música da Xuxa Lua de
Cristal? Ela fala assim: "Tudo que eu
quiser, o cara lá de cima vai me dar.
Tudo que eu quiser, o cara lá de cima
vai me dar. Me dar toda coragem que
puder, que não me falte força para
lutar."
Tá vendo?
Deus, sua crença, sua entidade, sua
energia, sua matemática, o que você
quiser acreditar, não vai te dar o que
você quer. Ele vai te dar força para
lutar. E é por isso que nós estamos
aqui. Sejam firmes, fortes, resilientes.
Apesar, né, dos pesares, da angústia, a
gente toma o nosso café e segue adiante
todos os dias. Vamos voltar.
Vamos voltar porque senão daqui a pouco
eu tô chorando aqui. Vamos falar de
doação. Vamos lá então. Vamos falar de
doação. Quando a gente fala aqui do
contrato de doação, obrigada, viu,
gente? Eu amo muito vocês. Eu quero
dizer para vocês que nos momentos, eu
sei que vocês têm uma rotatividade muito
grande, né? a cada prova são alunos
diferentes. Enfim, em 2021 eu passei um
momento muito difícil na minha vida e eu
encontrei força nos meus alunos daquele
momento. E hoje também algo me sublima
de uma maneira muito muito importante,
muito forte, muito firme. Eu tenho
certeza que eh independentemente do que
aconteceu, estarei aqui dando minhas
aulas firme e forte e contribuindo,
ainda que de uma maneira muito singela,
muito simplória, muito pequena e humilde
na vida de cada um. Tá, vamos lá.
Obrigada. Então, vamos lá. Doação. A
doação é, você sabe o que que é doação,
né? Todo mundo já recebeu uma doação na
vida, nem que seja dos nossos avós ou
dos nossos pais entregando aquele
dinheirinho pra gente ali, como se
tivesse passando drogas, né? Com a
mãozinha fechada. Olha, meu filho, isso
aqui é para você. Então, todo mundo já
passou por uma doação aqui. A doação, eu
quero que você eh entenda
que a doação depende de aceitação.
Quem recebe a doação,
quem recebe a doação, tem que aceitar
receber a doação. Você não pode jogar o
bem em cima da pessoa do Neida, né? tem
que aceitar receber a doação.
Pra aceitar.
Se a pessoa te der o prazo para aceitar,
você tem que aceitar nesse prazo.
E se você permanecer em silêncio,
o silêncio
implica em anuência.
implica em
anuência,
tá? Implica em anuência
se for uma doação pura. O que que é a
doação pura? É aquela doação que você
entrega
sem exigir nada em troca.
O oposto da doação pura é a doação
onerosa, que é a doação com encargo,
que é aquela doação assim: "Te dou o
carro para que você eh promova o
transporte das crianças.
Te dou a casa para que você instituou
uma creche." Isso é uma doação com
encargo, tá?
Vamos lá.
Então, o silêncio
na doação
pode implicar
em anuência
em se tratando
de doação pura.
via de regra, gente. E aqui uma coisa
que vocês confundem muito
é que a doação
é um contrato
escrito.
É um contrato escrito. Isso é a regra.
Mas você sabia que pode ser verbal?
pode ser verbal, ou seja,
pode ser verbal se estiver relacionada à
doação de bens
móveis
de pequeno valor. Então, a doação, via
de regra é escrita, mas pode ser verbal
quando se tratar de doação de bens
móveis,
de bens móveis de pequeno valor.
Tá, professora? Posso fazer doação
para o nascituro?
Pode, pode fazer doação pro nascituro.
Posso fazer doação para o absolutamente
incapaz? Quem é o único absolutamente
incapaz que nós temos?
Quem é o único absolutamente incapaz?
Nós temos o nascituro,
que é aquele que tá dentro do ventre
materno, e o absolutamente incapaz é
aquele que tem menos de 16 anos.
Posso fazer doação pro nascituro. Gente,
a doação pro nascituro, ela precisa ser
aceita
pelo representante.
Chá de fralda.
E o absolutamente incapaz, eu posso
fazer doação pro menor de 16 anos. De
boa. Inclusive, dispensa aceitação.
Dispensa aceitação. Isso aqui caiu na
prova da OAB. Dispensa aceitação. Se for
se for
uma doação pura, como eu expliquei para
você,
tá? Se for uma doação pura,
dá o print nessa tela aí.
A próxima tela eu já vou trazer pronta
para você,
é sobre revogação da doação.
Revogação da doação é você voltar atrás
na doação. Te dei uma coisa e eu vou
tomar de volta. Eu posso tomar de volta
a coisa doada por dois motivos. Dá uma
olhada aqui. Por ingratidão do
donatário. Por ingratidão do donatário
ou
por inexecução do encargo. Iexecução do
encargo é o mais fácil da gente
observar. Te dou a casa para que você
institua uma creche. Isso é uma doação
com encargo. Te dou a fazenda para que
você construa uma igreja para os colonos
locais. Isso já caiu na prova.
Se você não cumpre o encargo que eu
estabeleci, eu vou revogar a doação.
Ponto.
Por ingratidão do donatário. Donatário é
aquele que recebe a doação.
O cara é um fela da mãe.
Ele é um fela da mãe. E ele te sacaneou.
Quando ele te sacaneou, você descobriu
quais são as sacanagens. É qualquer
sacanagem, professora Nani,
[limpando a garganta] não. Olha aqui.
Por ingratidão do donatário, você pode
revogar nas causas do 557,
que são essas aqui, ó. Se o donatou,
atentou contra a vida do doador, tentou
matar o doador, matou o doador, cometeu
crime de homicídio doloso contra ele, se
cometeu ofensa física, se injuriou, se
podendo ministrar alimentos, negou os
alimentos,
tá? Contra
cônjuge, ascendente, descendente, irmão
do doador, também pode revogar. teve
conhecimento, ciência desses
acontecimentos,
você tem um ano para ajuizar a ação de
revogação da doação, tá bom? Certo?
Um outro ponto que eu quero trabalhar
com você
é sobre
fiança.
Fiança sempre aparece.
E fiança, gente, é uma modalidade de
contrato acessório para garantir o
cumprimento de uma outra obrigação. É
muito comum no contrato de eh locação,
né? estabelecer fiança no contrato de
locação. Como que a gente pode observar
isso? Dá uma olhada aqui. A fiança é uma
garantia fidejussória,
ou seja, é um pacto acessório.
Imagina que eu tenho aqui o contrato
principal entre Maria, credora, e
Antônio devedor.
Se a gente estipular um contrato de
fiança, esse contrato de fiança é entre
o credor e o fiador. Não tem nada a ver
com o devedor. muito embora a gente
esteja assegurando este devedor,
tá? A gente esteja assegurando este
devedor,
é sempre um contrato escrito, benéfico e
de interpretação restritiva. Eu não
posso presumir que o fiador vai eh
cumprir mais do que o que deveria,
tá? E o ponto chave é um contrato entre
credor e fiador.
Dois pontos que são cobrados em prova,
aliás, três pontos. Se o fiador for
casado, o cônjuge tem que dar a
anuência. Artigo 1647.
Se for fiador no contrato de locação,
tá vendo aqui?
Ele perde o bem de família. É o fiador
que por acionado no contrato de locação,
se ele não paga a dívida, ele perde o
próprio bem de família. Perde real,
oficial, perde o próprio bem de família.
Ah, professor, a única casa que ele
mora, coitado. Pois muito que bem, a
única casa que ele mora, coitado.
Tá?
Existe o benefício de ordem, professora?
Que que é o benefício de ordem? é exigir
que primeiro sejam executados os bens do
fiador,
sejam executados os bens do fiador
para depois ser cobrado o devedor.
Mas pode ser que tenha renúncia a esse
benefício de ordem. Então o fiador ele
pode ele pode ali ter uma renúncia
do benefício de ordem. Quando ele
renuncia ao benefício de ordem, você tem
que ficar atento ao que a questão cobra.
Quando ele renuncia ao benefício de
ordem, ele pode ser acionado na linha de
frente. Tipo, o credor não precisa nem
cobrar, né? O credor não precisa nem
cobrar o fiador.
O credor não precisa nem cobrar o
devedor, já cobra direto o fiador.
Perdão. E gente, batata questão de prova
que eu coloquei no simulado e uma galera
errou e que não vai errar mais.
Se eu tenho mais de um fiador,
eles são solidários entre si, via de
regra, tá? Se eu tenho mais de um
fiador, eles são solidários entre si,
via de regra, tá bom? E gente, essas são
as questões que eu eh queria comentar
com você de contratos.
Se você quiser dar o print nas telinhas,
vamos aqui, ó,
dá os prints aí bonitinho. A gente
conversou sobre um monte de temas sobre
contratos,
né?
Acredito que deva vir alguma questão
relacionada a esses temas. Aí
no nosso curso, eu já coloquei lá
lindamente para vocês a parte da lei
geral
de contratos ou de seguros, perdão,
lei geral de seguros.
Vou falar aqui por via de regra,
professora. Deixa eu dar o print. a
gente chegando na tela, eu falo de novo.
Dá o print. Dá o print. Por que que
quando eu tenho dois fiadores via de
regra, eles são solidários? Porque se eu
tenho dois fiadores, a lei estabelece
que no contrato, se não tiver previsto
que os dois são obrigados, né, metade
metade cada um pela dívida toda, eles
serão solidários. Então, no silêncio do
contrato, a regra é que a dívida é
solidária. Então, o credor pode acionar,
cobrar o todo de qualquer um dos
devedores.
Tudo bem? Beleza, beleza. Show de bola.
Beijo, beijo para você. Qualquer coisa,
tô aqui no YouTube em direito, como
nunca se viu e também lá no Instagram
@robertakeiros.
Beijo para você. Fica bem, continue
estudando, força. Tá todo mundo no mesmo
barco, não se iluda. A vida não é fácil
para ninguém. A grama do vizinho não é
mais verde que a sua. De repente ela
pode ser verde porque ela é falsa. E é
sobre isso. Tá bom? Beijo para vocês.
Até a próxima. Ciao. Ciao.
[música]